josh tomlin coming out of the bullpen
again to start for atlanta getting five
innings or more from the staff has been
an issue
hopefully josh tomlin can provide some
length and some
some stability as another shot to left
ozuna broke in but drifts back
and he ties a record held by many three
put outs and tomlin
a one two three first and here come the
braves
and now patrick corbin ready to go to
work against the braves
oh patrick corbin takes that one hard on
the back
the ground ball up the middle right
there is the
third baseman key boom flipping to
turner throws
onto first it's a double play to retire
the side
and a swing and a miss cabrera gave
tomlin a free strike and josh took
advantage of that he set down the first
for an order
eric thames back in there
that one came back and it's hammered
into the corner and a fair ball one
hopping behind duval
brock holt running on the pitch coming
home he
is safe the ball's on the ground
and eric thames drives in holt with a
two-out double
here's the pitch swing and a miss and
darnold down on strikes first strike out
for corbin
so now the batter is tyler flowers the
catcher batting eighth the one-two swing
and a miss
at the slider ball in the dirt runner
takes off gold is going to throw to
third and get the force on the strikeout
to retire the side as he looked up and
flowers took off was in his line of
sight
and so corbin's walked a couple of men
and that sets the table beautifully for
freddie freeman
swang and a miss ozuna with a base hit
inside the first base bag his first time
up
hard hit trey turner right there the
short way to garcia and that's her out
of the inning
tomlin's done an excellent job
he promptly hits it to left riley drifts
back ozuna joins him austin says he has
it
and just like that two are out nothing
in one pitch from tomlin
popped up towards left field charging
over marcelo zuna he is there and there
is out number three
we've all seven for 20 against nationals
pitching this year with a couple of
homers
lined toward left and fair headed for
the corner
riley rumbles around second he's on his
way to third he's gonna have to stop
it's a ground rule double
the ball bounced over that low fence and
that's tough break riley would have
scored from first on that
hot shot to left tyler struck out his
first time up
and there it is to flowers swung on it
in the air to right field towards the
line here comes eden and he cannot make
the play
it's off his glove and into the corner
it rolls this will score riley they send
home duvall
he will score rounding second and
heading for third as flowers
make it a two rbi stand up triple out of
tyler flowers
did it bounce off the netting ball
clearly fair the braves are going to get
two runs the question is will flowers be
at second or third
and the umpires are going to say the
ball did hit the cutout after the
conversation so give flowers a two-run
double bass is loaded
freddy over two finally hit a grand slam
for the first time in his career a few
nights ago
pitch up fly ball left field
brock holt huge pitch
for patrick corbin ready to get things
going first
swinging a high fly ball wallop deep
left holt will turn and admire that baby
long gone by ozuna but a long home run
for marcel his 13th of the year
and the braves extend their lead that
ball was
assassinated 12 straight games jeff with
a home run for the braves
they see the church tomlin has thrown 67
pitches 44
in the strike zone work out something
with trey turner who just broke his bat
tomlin broke his heart
and works a one two three sixth inning
he is rolling 3-1 atlanta
but again a second chance for freddie to
hit a grand
slam in this series and pitches to
freeman and it's hit in the air left
center field and deep on his horse's
hult
at the track looks up it is another
grand slam for freddie freeman
two grand slams in the series after no
grand slams in the first 10 years of his
major league career
they're loaded for marcelo zuna
fly ball the other way eaton retreat
still going back
can't get it it's over his head here
comes freddie around third it's a basis
clearing double for
ozuna bryce wilson celebrates a return
to the major leagues
his first opening day roster in 2020
appeared in six total games
last year in 2019 and
turner loud sound deep center
inciarte back it's off the wall above
his head
chugging around third and scoring is
adam eaton
and heading for third is trey turner
with his 22nd extra base hit
and his league leading 58th hit of the
season
so here's as drooble who's two for 13 in
the series
he's going to go where the shift isn't
and now it's 10-3 and nobody out
carter keyboard the final hope popped
him up
and freddie freeman is there and the
braves have taken care of washington
10-3
is your final score